Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one nine area code w is nine one nine North
Carolina.
Is that me?
Yes it is.
Oh, hi David.
Wow, this is cool.
I didn't expect you to actually answer me.
That is North Carolina.
It's in Raleigh, North Carolina.
It's in Raleigh.
Um, so, um, I guess my question, um, especially
involving current events in both Australia
and, and uh, I ran after last night.
Um, I was wondering, um, if there was anything
that you could say for those.
Um, I guess I was wondering if there was any,
um, if there was any advice you had for those
who were, who suffered from, uh, how do I
say this?
Who suffer from, uh, eco anxiety and world
issues, anxiety that, uh, you could say to
help?
I don't know.
I mean, listen, here's the thing.
This is, I, I hesitate to do this because
I think that political and civic engagement
is so important.
So I, I, I'm saying this only take this for
what you want, right?
But a lot of the stuff that's going on around
the world, if you tune out, you're going to
be okay.
And I don't mean this flippantly, I just,
I see so many people including in my personal
life who are just so effected by the disastrous
what's going on with the environment, the
embarrassment around the world.
That is Trump.
I actually understand some people who go,
Hey, you know what?
My life's, my lifespan is limited.
Uh, I am just going to seek the, the most
pleasurable and least difficult life possible.
I'm just going to focus on my day to day enjoyment.
I'm going to try to tune out a lot of what's
going on.
Like I, I don't think that that's good as
a society, but at the individual level I get
doing it, you know, because it's, it's getting
so bad right now and I'm not necessarily recommending
that you do that, but I would understand that
if you did for your own wellbeing.
[inaudible]
I've, I've tried, I've tried that in the past
and it didn't, I'm more, um, I'm trying to
face this, trying to get more, I'm trying
to face this by getting more involved in things,
go into more fruits and have been like speaking,
speaking out publicly about it.
I see.
In other words, you're not looking, you're
not looking to, um, you're not looking to
just feel better.
You're looking to actually make an impact,
I guess, but I just don't, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, it depends on what issue,
you know, what you would do for the environment
would be different than what you might do
for local government in terms of whether getting
more involved makes sense.
But that's good.
I mean, listen, you, you know, when I say
I understand people completely checking out,
I don't think that it's good and I think it's
better for society.
You know, if we all check out, then they get
a free and clear path to the hoop, so to speak,
to use a sports analogy.
So I actually think that it's right that you
want to get more involved.
I, you know, we'd have to talk more about
exactly how you would do it, but I, I, uh,
I applaud your instincts because it would
be far easier at this point to say, I just
can't do it.
I'm checking out.
No, I've, I've tried that before and it just
makes the [inaudible] it just makes going
back to, it just makes going back to things
even worse,
a diet that I totally understand.
Well listen, uh, I appreciate that you want
to get more involved and let's, you know,
the, the first thing we can do is at every
level, let's do the best we can.
In November of 2020, there are local, state
and national elections.
In 2020, we're trying to remove Trump.
We're trying to take back the Senate, their
city councils, governorships.
Let's take the next 10 months and focus electorally.
Uh, and uh, and then hopefully the changes
that come from the November election will
give us four years or two years depending
on which office you're talking about to try
to make more change.
I think that's the immediate plan.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you David.
I really appreciate you answering this for
me.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much and I hope to hear from
you again.